>> Sean: THANK YOU AND WELCOME
TO HANNITY.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH THE
FOX NEWS ALERT.
THE PRESIDENT JUST CAPPED OFF A
VERY BUSY DAY ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, A HUGE MASSIVE RALLY AND
CROWD IN WINSTON-SALEM,
NORTH CAROLINA.
LOOK AT THIS CROWD, LOOK AT
WINSTON-SALEM TONIGHT.
TAKE A LONG LOOK AND ASK
YOURSELF -- THAT’S NOT AT ALL
THE VIDEO I WANTED TO SHOW.
HOW MANY PEOPLE FEEL THIS WAY
ABOUT THE WEEK AND THE FRAIL
JOE BIDEN?
EARLIER, THE PRESIDENT ALSO
DELIVERED A SPEECH IN JUPITER,
FLORIDA, WHERE HE WAS ALSO MET
BY MASSIVE CROWDS.
MEANWHILE, JOE BIDEN SPENT TODAY
IN HIS BASEMENT BUNKER DOING
NOTHING AS PER USUAL AND WE WILL
HAVE THAT IN A MINUTE.
APPARENTLY, HE NEEDED TO REST
AFTER A VERY ROUGH WEEKEND ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
MORE WEIRD GAFFES AND STRANGE
STATEMENTS, MORE CONSTANT
CONFUSION.
LOOKED LIKE A DEER IN THE
HEADLIGHTS.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THE WORST
MOMENTS FROM THIS WEEKEND AND A
CRITICAL WARNING THAT THE REST
OF THE MEDIA MOB WON’T TELL YOU
ABOUT AND THAT IS MAIL AND VOTER
FRAUD THIS COMING FROM A
DEMOCRATIC OPERATIVE WHO
ORGANIZED AND COORDINATED
MAIL-IN BALLOT VOTER FRAUD IN
MANY PREVIOUS ELECTIONS AND
LATER, BRAD KNEW DISTURBING
VIDEO FROM THIS WEEKEND’S FAR
LEFT RIOTS.
FIRST, WE START WITH A VERY
IMPORTANT OBSERVATION ABOUT THE
2020 RACE.
56 DAYS FROM NOW.
AS WE SPEAK, THERE IS NOTHING
THAT I COULD OTHERWISE DESCRIBE
AS WHAT IS A SICKENING ALIGNMENT
AMONG SO MANY OF THE POWERFUL
ELITIST GROUPS IN THIS COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
99.9%, WEEK REPUBLICANS COME OF
THE ONES THAT ALWAYS DEMANDED IF
YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE, YOU HAVE
TO SUCK IT UP AND SUPPORT THEIR
CANDIDATES, THE ONES THEY
PREFERRED, YOU HAVE ALL THE
DEEP STATE BUREAUCRATS THAT
DESPERATELY WANT TRUMP OUT, SO
THEY CAN RETURN TO THEIR
NEFARIOUS DEEDS, THAN THE 99.9%
OF THE MOB AND THE MEDIA, 99.9%.
"NEW YORK TIMES,"
"WASHINGTON POST," ALL OF THEM
FOR THE MOST PART, NEARLY EVERY
SINGLE SOLITARY SO-CALLED CABLE
NEWS NETWORK, ALL FAKE NEWS.
EVERY BROADCAST CHANNEL, ABC,
NBC, CBS AND HOLLYWOOD SNOBS AND
ELITISTS AND MANY PRO ATHLETES
WEIRD THEY ALL SPEAK IN ONE
VOICE.
ALL WORKING ON THE ONE GOAL, ONE
OUTCOME ON NOVEMBER THE 3RD.
THEY WANT TO BEAT DONALD TRUMP.
NOW IT’S TIME FOR A HANNITY
HISTORY LESSON AND WHAT WE CALL
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE REMEMBER, I
KNOW FOR YEARS HAVE GONE BY FAST
BUT THE SAME EXACT THING WAS
HAPPENING FOUR YEARS AGO IN
2016, SAME GROUPS ALL LINED UP
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
THEY LASTED DONALD TRUMP’S
CAMPAIGN, MOCKED HIM FROM
RUNNING AND ALL MADE THE
PREDICTION HE CAN’T WIN, ALMOST
ALL OF THEM SAID NO CHANCE OF
WINNING.
THEY ORCHESTRATED THE BIGGEST
SMEAR CAMPAIGN IN HISTORY AND
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER SOME OF THIS.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN SAYING
HE WILL RUN FOR PRESIDENT AS A
REPUBLICAN WHICH IS SURPRISING
BECAUSE I ASSUMED HE WAS RUNNING
AS A JOKE.
>> DO IT.
JUST DO IT.
LOOK AT ME.
DO IT.
A CAMPAIGN CHECK NOW ON BEHALF
OF THIS COUNTRY WHICH DOES NOT
WANT YOU TO BE PRESIDENT BUT
BADLY WANTS YOU TO RUN.
>> THIS MAN HAS GOT SOME
MOMENTUM AND WE BETTER BE READY
FOR THE FACT HE MIGHT BE LEADING
THE REPUBLICAN TICKET.
>> I KNOW YOU DON’T BELIEVE THAT
BUT I’M GOING TO GO ON.
>> A RICH REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
HAS THE BEST CHANCE OF WINNING
THE GENERAL ELECTION?
>> OF THE DECLARED ONES RIGHT
NOW, DONALD TRUMP.
[LAUGHTER]
>> MR. TRUMP, ANSWER YOUR CALL
FOR POLITICAL HONESTY.
I JUST WANT TO SAY YOU’RE NOT
GOING TO BE PRESIDENT,
ALL RIGHT?
IT’S BEEN FUN.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA WILL GO DOWN
AS PERHAPS THE WORST PRESIDENT
IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES EXCLAMATION POINT.
@REALDONALDTRUMP, AT LEAST I
WILL GO DOWN AS A PRESIDENT.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS A CANDIDATE
FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> LET ME ASSURE EVERY PERSON
HERE, DONALD TRUMP WILL NOT
BECOME PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE DONALD TRUMP
STANDING UP ONE DAY AND
DELIVERING A STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS?
>> I CAN IMAGINE IN A SATURDAY
NIGHT SKATE.
>> DONALD TRUMP WE PROJECT WILL
WIN IN KENTUCKY WITH HIS EIGHT
ELECTORAL VOTES.
KANSAS WITH ITS SIX ELECTORAL
VOTES, NEBRASKA, FIVE ELECTORAL
VOTES, UTAH, WISCONSIN, AN
IMPROBABLE POLITICAL JOURNEY
WITH AN ASTOUNDING UPSET
VICTORY.
>> WE LEARNED THEIR COLLECTIVE
OPINIONS, PREDICTIONS, WERE NOT
ONLY WRONG, BUT THEY WERE ALL
MEANINGLESS.
HERE IS A SIMPLE TRUTH.
THE WASHINGTON SWAMP WILL NOT
DECIDE THE SELECTION, NEITHER
WILL THOSE HOLLYWOOD SNOBS.
THE TRUTH IS, NONE OF THESE
PEOPLE MATTER.
THEY WERE OPINIONS DO NOT
MATTER.
FAKE NEWS DOESN’T MATTER.
THE POWER RESTS WITH ALL OF YOU.
LOOK AT NORTH CAROLINA TONIGHT.
THAT’S NOT THE MOB, THAT’S NOT
THE SWAMP, THAT’S NOT HOLLYWOOD
ELITES.
THAT IS YOU, WEEK, THE PEOPLE.
YOU WILL DECIDE.
YOU GET TO BE THE ULTIMATE JERRY
AND JUST 56 SHORT DAYS.
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WE
WILL DECIDE ON THE FUTURE OF
THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
THE STAKES HAVE NEVER BEEN
HIGHER.
BY THE WAY FOR INFORMATIONAL
PURPOSES ONLY ON Hannity.com,
WE HAVE AN INTERACTIVE MAP THAT
SHOWS YOU EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT WHERE TO VOTE IN YOUR
DISTRICT, WHEN YOU GET TO
REGISTER, WHEN IS THE
REGISTRATION, WINDOWS EARLY
VOTING START, WHEN DOES IT END,
AND SO MUCH MORE.
WHO WAS RUNNING FOR CONGRESS, IS
THERE A SENATE RACE IN YOUR
STATE, BE SURE TO CHECK OUT
Hannity.com FOR ALL THE DETAILS
AND INFORMATION YOU COULD EVER
WANT.
THIS IS THE SINGLE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL ELECTION OF OUR
LIFETIME AND THE MEDIA, THE MOB,
THE DEMOCRATS, HOLLYWOOD ELITES
AND ALL OF THEIR ALLIES ARE NOT
TELLING YOU THE TRUTH.
THEY’VE LIED TO YOU FOR FOUR
STRAIGHT PLUS YEARS AND AS WE
SPEAK, THEY ARE TURNING A BLIND
EYE TO THE OBVIOUS AND SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE WHOLE COUNTRY
IS TALKING ABOUT IT, THEY TALK
ABOUT IT BEHIND CLOSED DOORS,
DEMOCRATS EVEN TELL ME.
MEDIA MOB PEOPLE EVEN TELL ME.
JOE BIDEN’S STRENGTH, STAMINA,
ALERTNESS, MENTAL ACUITY, THEY
ARE ALL WORRIED ABOUT IT JUST
LIKE THE RIOTS.
IT’S A MYTH, IT’S NOT HAPPENING.
THEY ARE IGNORING A WALKING
DISASTER INVITED AND THEY KNOW
IT.
THEY ARE SO DESPERATE TO BEAT
DONALD TRUMP THAT THEY ARE
WILLING TO PUT THIS COUNTRY
LITERALLY IN THE POSITION OF
SUPPORTING SOMEBODY WHO WOULD BE
ELECTED PRESIDENT AT HIS, THAT
IS FRAIL, THAT IS OBVIOUSLY A
CANDIDATE THAT IS NOT UP TO THE
JOB, THE HARDEST JOB IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD, PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, LEADER OF THE
FREE WORLD.
FOR EXAMPLE, DURING ONE VIRTUAL
EVENT ON MONDAY, BIDEN STRUGGLED
MIGHTILY TO ANSWER A QUESTION
WITHOUT A TELEPROMPTER.
ACTUALLY, WITH A TELEPROMPTER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
WILL YOUR ADMINISTRATION DO TO
HELP GIVE US THAT CHANCE?
THANK YOU.
>> MOVE IT UP HERE.
THERE USED TO BE A BASIC BARGAIN
IN THIS COUNTRY.
WORKERS SHARED IN THE WEALTH
THAT WORK HELPED CREATE.
>> Sean: LAST WEEK, THE BIDEN
TOWN HALL IN KENOSHA, WISCONSIN,
ONE PERSON HAD TO COMPLAIN SHE
WAS BEING FORCED TO READ OFF A
WRITTEN SCRIPT.
JUST THINK IF THIS WAS
DONALD TRUMP, THINK FOR A
MINUTE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WAS TOLD TO GO OFF THIS
PAPER, BUT I CAN’T.
WE NEED THE TRUTH, AND THE TRUTH
OF THE MATTER IS, WE ARE HEAVILY
ANGRY.
NOT ANGRY AS TO WHERE PEOPLE SAY
THEY ARE PROTESTING, IT’S A
DIFFERENT BETWEEN A PROTESTER
AND A RIDER.
A VERY BIG DIFFERENCE.
>> Sean: THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN
SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF IT IF THIS
WAS ANY REPUBLICAN, THE MEDIA
MOB WOULD HAVE A FIELD DAY AND
INSTEAD, THEY COVER UP THE
TRUTH, ACT LIKE REALITY IS NOT
HAPPENING.
THEY HAVE ZERO MORAL COMPASS,
INTELLECTUAL HONESTY OR
CURIOSITY.
IS SUCH A DISSERVICE TO YOU, WE,